[Applause]
[Music]
sevenths not that bad
plus he just qualified for the
Paralympics every four years we spend
two weeks watching athletes compete for
a chance to be on a box of disgusting
cereal that nobody's bought since the
50s who wants to spend two weeks in
London the food sucks it's always
raining and no one looks like Christian
Bale it's just like Boston with a big
clock the Olympics haven't been fun
since 92 when the dream team destroyed
every country they played by 40 points
and pregnant it half the bitches in
Barcelona yeah it's not a coincidence
that Spain suddenly started cranking out
beautiful mixed-raced ballers the Greeks
only invented the Olympics because they
needed something to watch while eating
their delicious salads that's why I
decided to get in on this action and do
every single sport in the Olympics in
record time for the 2012 Tosh point
Olympic Games
here's Daniel Tosh with an effeminate
warm-up routine that has this announcer
fully around he loads into the blocks in
the historic Tosh point Olympiad is
under way a ridiculously short dash into
the hurdles into the high jump he's no
stranger than working the pole is it the
shoes flips the crossbar and waiting for
him on the bad is a wrestler let's get
it on it's over for gold so far county
make it vibe Tosh looks like
fly stings like Biddy judo
now he's just piling on it's as if he's
been training all morning he looks dead
that's gonna make the rematch tricky
time to throw stuff he Chuck's the metal
frisbee the metal softball Tosh races
through the field events like a
barrel-chested Oh hits his head on the
release can we see a replay no ok
forehand followed by a backhand
then the two headed back in into a
whatever the hell that is a big show the
judges aren't going to like that yeah
Yolo he cleans it he jerks it and even
has time to get a quick nap in this is
where Tosh truly excels handling balls
spikes the volleyball right into a rivet
camera water polo ball fake and a header
for go and look out dream team because
ladaniel just brought the house down
shots up for gymnastics and let's just
say he powdered his nose for a little
extra energy take that G Series just
delightful suck a baguette it's China
Bela Karolyi right out to congratulate
it must be nice to hug a man and not a
12 year old girl that will never have a
period that counts as equestrian seems
like a stretch remember nobody needs an
assault rifle for any reason he'll
probably get a low score because of that
splash that doesn't seem to bother him
as he swims
the end of the pool and white and the
sailing and rowing and here it is the
final wagon with an apple oh yes he's
done it the caches are factoring in time
distance the degree of difficulty Daniel
Tosh just made Michael Phelps look like
a lazy bitch what a great day for
America but it's completed all the
Olympic events in record time now can we
start football season so in sport
Americans care about I don't know why
everyone's so upset about blood doping
makes sports so much easier
[Music]
[Applause]